damit hallo zu dieser breaking news
sendung mit einer wirklich guten
nachricht eine nachricht auf die wir den
ganzen tag eigentlich seit
sonntagnachmittag gewartet haben die
kleine julia aus berlin die seit sonntag
so gesucht wurde die dramatisch
verschwunden war im wald in tschechien
ist gefunden worden und das mädchen lebt
das ist die großartige nachricht an
diesem dienstagnachmittag gerade von der
polizei in tschechien bestätigt julia
wurde gefunden und sie lebt das kleine
mädchen hat irgendwie diesem jahr zwei
tage langen alptraum im wald überlebt
alleine überlebt und hier sehen wir den
tweet der tschechischen polizei vor
wenigen minuten bestätigen die beamten
dass das mädchen lebt dass es ihr den
umständen entsprechend okay geht und
dass sie jetzt von sanitätern betreut
wird am sonntag der wahl das kleine
mädchen julia mit ihrer familie eben
wandern im tschechisch deutschen
grenzgebiet und dann beim spielen
plötzlich nicht mehr aus dem wald zurück
gekommen wie bei bild haben sie seit
sonntag über diese dramatische über
diesen dramatischen fall kann man nennt
am laufenden gehalten sie informiert und
eben jetzt diese wirklich gute nachricht
auf die wir so lange gewartet haben es
geht julia den umständen entsprechend
gut sie lebt und die polizei sie hat sie
gefunden und dort vor ort steht jetzt
unser kollege jörg völkerling mit den
aktuellsten informationen jörg sag uns
einmal was genau hast du dort vor ort
gehört und erfahren
ja wir haben alle gänsehaut denn das
ging ja wirklich ein richtiger schrei
der erleichterung durch die reihen der
rettungskräfte vor zwei minuten ist der
sprecher der oberpfälzischen polizei
auch vor die medien getreten hat diese
information der tschechen auch bestätigt
er hat uns in die mikrofone gesagt
waldarbeiter förster haben ein mädchen
gefunden es war im wald es war
unterkühlt es lebt aber und er hat
wirklich fast in tränen gesagt wir
können bestätigen es sieht alles sehr
gut aus julia ist also in obhut von
sanitätern sie hat es offenbar geschafft
unvorstellbar zwei tage lang über diesen
echt unwirtlichen bedingungen im wald zu
überleben das sind ganz frische
informationen wir wissen noch nichts
näheres über den gesundheitszustand aber
jeder kann sich vorstellen so leicht
bekleidet wie sie war ohne essen ohne
trinken bei temperaturen nahe dem
gefrierpunkt
das war wirklich das stand spitz auf
knopf das waren jetzt 48 stunden heute
nachmittag die zeit wäre abgelaufenen wo
wirkliche profis gesagt hätten da
besteht noch eine überlebenschance und
jetzt ist diese information also
wirklich bestätigt wurden und noch kurz
bevor der polizeisprecher hier vor die
mikrofone gegangen ist machte sich die
nachricht bei den
rettungshundestaffeln bei den sanitätern
feuerwehrleuten bergwacht leuten breit
man hörte wie die riefen das ist ja mal
geil um sich teilweise in den armen
lagen also das ist ein gefühl der
erleichterung das ist wirklich kaum in
worte zu fassen ich bekomme hier auch
gänsehaut wenn du das so schildert jörg
wie haben die anderen leute da drum
herum reagiert und vor allem haben die
da wirklich noch daran geglaubt dass es
am ende dieses tages so ein wunder geben
könnte dass man julia wirklich noch
lebendig findet
ich denke hier gilt einfach das motto
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt und niemand
wollte diese hoffnung aufgeben denn das
hat diese 800 rettungskräfte aus ganz
bayern wirklich am laufen gehalten und
hat sie motiviert hier einfach weiter zu
suchen wir waren erst vor 20 minuten
konnten wir hier in die einsatzzentrale
die ist beim zoll am grenzübergang in
furth im wald in diesem haus hinter mir
da sind die tschechischen rettungskräfte
zusammengezogen mit den deutschen
feuerwehrleute polizisten die
kriminalpolizei aus regensburg die da
ein lagezentrum eingerichtet haben wir
haben die karten gesehen von diesem
riesigen waldgebiet wirklich unwirklich
unwirtliche bedingungen mit hängen
klüften die bürgen abschnitten zuletzt
es noch eine alpin rettungsgruppe aus
oberbayern hierher gerufen wurden die
jetzt offenbar gar nicht mehr zum
einsatz kommen mussten letztlich waren
es also offenbar tatsächlich
tschechische waldarbeiter förster die
diese gegen natürlich auch am besten
kennen wie ihre westentasche kennen die
dieses mysterium letztlich aufgeklärt
haben und dieser verzweifelten familie
aus berlin jetzt endlich hoffnung und
gewissheit geben konnten dass es alles
ein gutes ende gefunden hat und alle
menschen hier in der region in der
böhmerwald region von bayern und
tschechien haben wirklich mit geburt
diese zwei tage weil jeder diese urangst
der eltern teilt wenn ein kind aus den
augen verschwindet und man nicht weiß wo
ist es brauch dass meine hilfe kann ich
ihm helfen und man ist selbst hilflos
man kann nichts tun auch die eltern
wurden von notfallseelsorgern betreut
sie waren ja zum nichtstun verdammt und
jeder kann wirklich nachvollziehen was
für einen riesen felsbrocken jetzt den
eltern als last von der vom herz
gefallen ist jörg wenn wir beide
sprechen höre ich gerade von unserer
nachrichtenredaktion das offenbar acht
kilometer zwischen dem ort wo das
mädchen verschwunden ist und dem ort wo
sie jetzt gefunden worden liegt also
doch eine ziemlich große distanz und
natürlich die frage die dann in den
nächsten tagen geklärt werden muss wie
sie dahin gekommen und was ist in der
zwischenzeit passiert aber eigentlich
ist das auch alles egal denn hauptsache
julia lebt und julia ist gefunden
und eben die große erleichterung bei uns
allen und vor allem natürlich bei der
familie ist die familien noch in der
region können die jetzt ihre julia in
empfang nehmen
ich kann darüber keine gesicherten
angaben machen aber ich gehe natürlich
davon aus dass sie hier in der region
sind um einfach schnellstmöglich dann
auch zu ihrer tochter zukommen wenn man
sie findet denn neben der medizinischen
betreuung ist das natürlich das a und o
dass dieses kind das wirklich 48 stunden
auf sich allein gestellt war jetzt
wieder vertraute person um sich hat das
wird eine heilungsprozess einfach am
meisten beschleunigen und wir haben
jetzt ein paar informationen auch noch
bekommen wie dieser tag dieser sonntag
auch hier verlaufen ist warum dieses
kind dann einfach so verschwinden konnte
also die eltern waren ja in waldmünchen
untergebracht diese kleine familie ist
dann auf diesen stoff auf diesen
schwarzkopf berg hoch gelaufen waren an
gipfel die kinder sind ein bisschen vor
angelaufen haben wollen abzweig genommen
dann die eltern nicht mehr gefunden und
dann sind die beiden jungs der neffe und
der oder von der kleinen julia sind
zurückgelaufen in die arme einer
radfahrerin die sie dann mit den eltern
versöhnt hat sondern wie wir zusammen
gebracht hat und julia war wohl
zurückgeblieben während die beiden jungs
sich eben auf die suche nach den
erwachsenen gemacht hatten und als dann
diese gruppe wieder an diesem letzten
punkt wo julia war zurück gegangen ist
war julia auf einmal weg wie das ob
julia dann sozusagen es nicht mehr
ausgehalten hat ungeduldig geworden ist
und immer tiefer in diese weiten des
böhmerwaldes hinein gedrungen ist das
ist alles momentan spekulationen darüber
können wir keine gesicherten angaben
machen auch der pressesprecher der
polizei überfalls ist jetzt erstmal
dabei hier im lagezentrum sich ein
genaues bild zu verschaffen und
gesicherte informationen zu bekommen
aber was im moment an erster stelle
steht ist natürlich die medizinische
versorgung das kind ist unterkühltes
braucht nahrung das braucht flüssigkeit
das sind jetzt die dinge die wirklich
wichtig sind absolut jörg du kennst der
region ja ganz gut diesen böhmer bei
dieses grenzgebiet von bayerns zu
tschechien wie genau sieht es dort aus
und was eben war die große
herausforderung für die retter für die
suchkräfte in den vergangenen jahr fast
48 stunden muss man ja sagen
na ja das ist ein das sind sozusagen
zwei zusammenhängende nationalparke auf
der tschechischen seite und auf der
deutschen seite vollmer war das ist der
tschechischen nationalpark und der
bayerische wald der älteste deutsche
nationalpark das sind riesige
zusammenhängender waldstücke
es gibt hier auch große wolfs
populationen natürlich und das sind
einfach teilweise auch
klüfte gebirgige abschnitte wo man
hinein fallen kann es gibt dort alte
bunkeranlagen
wo man sozusagen wie in einem loch im
waldboden verschwinden kann es gab
witterungen von von hunden die dann
irgendwo im nichts enden
und natürlich das was dem kind zu
schaffen machte das machte den rettern
natürlich genauso zu schaffen also
sprich immer wieder regen kälte in der
nacht temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt
bis zu vier grad heute nacht
also dieser diese ständigen
wetterumschwünge auch das mobilfunknetz
ist sicherlich nicht stabil das sind
sprachbarrieren vielleicht auch
andererseits muss man sagen hier gerade
die tschechische und bayerischen retter
die polizei die haben hier ein
wirkliches sehr gut funktionierendes
system der zusammenarbeit aufgebaut da
gibt es keine grenzen wenn hier solche
großlagen sind dann legen die retter von
beiden seiten ihre kräfte zusammen man
sieht dass hier auch in dem lagezentrum
hinter mir wirklich die tschechen
genauso mit integriert sind und
eingebunden sind und es fahren dann auch
bei solchen sachen sofort auch das
bayerische rote kreuz fährt ohne großes
federlesen über die grenze und sucht
dann auf tschechischen staatsgebiet dann
nach dem kind das waren aber natürlich
auch die die schwierigkeiten der
vergangenen tage jörg du hast sozusagen
diesen platz hinter dir angesprochen wir
sehen da unterschiedliche
rettungsfahrzeuge was genau sind das für
einheiten die da im einsatz waren und
wir haben die auch ihren einsatz
gemeinsam koordiniert dass man eben am
ende ja sinnvoll in diesem so dichten
wald und schwer zugänglichen gebiet
überhaupt sinnvoll suchen konnte
wir haben im prinzip als wir jetzt vor
20 minuten im lagezentrum waren haben
wir nur karten gesehen die an der an dem
flipchart waren das waren einfach nur
eine große grüne fläche sozusagen mit
mit kleinen schwarzen strichen die
daneben wanderwege markieren ihre kleine
fähnchen gesehen die eben offenbar den
den letzten punkt von der sichtung von
julia markiert haben und von dort aus
von verschiedenen seiten haben dann
versucht diese rettungskräfte zum
beispiel diese alpinen rettungskräfte
die heute noch aus oberbayern dazu
gezogen worden sind von verschiedenen
seiten auf den berggipfel zu kommen wie
ein netz was sozusagen über diese
suchgebiet gezogen wurden ist
und man hat also man hat 40 suchende aus
ganz bayern hierher gebracht die
bergwachten die verschiedenen einheiten
der berg ist 1200 meter hoch insgesamt
war die zahl der rettungskräfte in
hochzeiten war bei mit 800 menschen
angegeben es sind immer wieder neue
kräfte auch nach gezogen wurden weil die
anderen natürlich auch irgendwann
erschöpft waren aber was ich gesagt habe
diesen diese hoffnung das kind noch
lebend zu finden solange auch noch die
minimal chance bestand die hat alle hier
beflügelt
wird wenn wir sprechen da sozusagen gibt
es immer neue informationen offenbar ist
julia in einem ort gefunden worden der
ceska kubitza heißt dort also ist das
mädchen aufgefunden worden und wir
wollen sie immer wieder wiederholen
julia lebt eben und ist von
rettungskräften auf gesammelt worden
wird jetzt betreut diese unglaublich ja
berauschende großartige nachricht am
dienstagnachmittag und jetzt nimmt und
so einmal mit in diesem moment du hast
es gesagt plötzlich gegen also gebrüll
freude geschreie los zwischen den
rettungskräften wie genau ist das
abgelaufen wie hat sich diese nachricht
verbreitet
ja ich selbst habe über diesen tweet der
technik der tschechischen polizei
erfahren dass es eben gute nachrichten
gebe während hier die anderen kollegen
kamerateams wirklich noch zusammen
standen und ja relativ entspannt schien
es schien sich noch nicht
herumgesprochen zu haben was davon
tschechischer seite für eine
bombastische nachricht eigentlich
gekommen ist ich bin dann selber hier
über den platz das ist also das zollamt
in furth im wald gegangen und habe
versucht verschiedene retter zu fragen
habt ihr was gehört habt ihr auch schon
die bestätigung dass das kind gefunden
worden ist überall ungläubiges
kopfschütteln
und dann war es tatsächlich eine sache
von von von sekunden das man gehört hat
es wurde geklatscht auf einmal hier
hinter mir hinter der absperrung und es
wurden leute lagen sich in den armen es
gab jubelschreie eine sanitäterin rief
das ist ja mal geil
das und dieses dieses gänsehautgefühl
das hat sich einfach bei jedem der hier
steht sei es auch vonseiten der
rettungskräfte polizeikräfte aber auch
von den berichterstattern
einfach breitgemacht das kann jeder der
kinder hat kann das nachvollziehen was
für eine befreiende nachricht das ist wo
ja im hinterkopf bei jedem sein musste
eigentlich
muss man das schlimmste letztlich auch
schon befürchten und dass das jetzt
nicht eingetreten ist das ist einfach
einfach eine fantastische nachricht an
diesem tag wo man gerade noch darüber
nachgedacht hat die einsatz die die
retter wie wird die nächste nacht
verbracht macht es überhaupt sinn bei
einbruch der dunkelheit noch mal rettern
dieses gebiet zu schicken oder wartet
man dann ab bis es neben morgen wieder
hell wird hubschrauber stand bereit er
konnte aber wegen der schlechten
wetterbedingungen wohl bis zuletzt auch
nicht starten
wärmebildkamera nach
48 stunden bei diesem dicht bewaldeten
gebiet ob das noch sinn gemacht hätte
ist die nächste frage aber all die
fragen die sind jetzt obsolet wir haben
die bestätigung aus tschechien wir haben
sie aus der oberpfalz aus deutschland
julia lebt sie wird versorgt und kann
hoffentlich in diesen minuten auch
wieder von ihren eltern von vater mutter
in die arme geschlossen werden ja die
polizei die hat sich gerade noch mal
geäußert und die sage neben julia lebt
sie ist unterkühlt und ins krankenhaus
gebracht worden also die aktuellste
informationen dass sich julia
mittlerweile im krankenhaus befindet was
natürlich auch gemessen an den umständen
eine gute nachricht ist denn dort kann
sie genau richtig eben betreut werden
behandelt werden völkerling hat das
gerade eben angesprochen zwei tage zwei
nächte im wald bei temperaturen um null
grad wenn wir noch einmal zurück
springen york zum sonntag dann war die
familie ja wann dann im wald und dann
einen moment den ja jeder vater jede
mutter kennt du drehst dich um und
plötzlich siehst du dein kind nicht mehr
es ist eben irgendwo um die ecke
abgebogen und das problem in dem fall
war eben dass julia überhaupt nicht mehr
zurückgekommen ist in den minuten und in
den stunden danach nicht die familie die
hat dann rettungskräfte gerufen dann
würde der bruder und der saison gefunden
aber julia die blieb verschollen und
jetzt fast 48 stunden später dann diese
unglaubliche nachricht jörg wenn ich
dich einmal persönlich fragen darf hast
du selbst noch lange geglaubt dass wir
hier stehen und diese großartige
nachricht vermelden können
ja als vater hofft man auch genauso wie
jeder der ritter hier dass das noch
möglich ist und ich hatte im hinterkopf
noch sonntag 15 uhr 16 uhr ist julia
verschwunden seitdem haben die eltern
gehofft und retter haben gesagt auch bei
uns von der bergwacht heute morgen in
der sendung live 48 stunden das ist noch
so eine option dann schließt sich dieses
fenster langsam und wir sind jetzt jetzt
sind diebe dienstagnachmittag kurz vor
16 uhr also solange denke ich mal bis 16
uhr gaben sich die retter auch noch und
bestand auch die realistische chance
noch und das ist jetzt auch tatsächlich
hat sich bewahrheitet aber muss man
trotzdem sagen nicht nicht aufgrund
dieser manpower sondern aufgrund der
lokalen forstarbeiter und förster die
dann letztlich das kind gefunden haben
jörg völkerling vor ort für uns der
diese unglaublich positive und
großartige nachricht vor ort für uns
recherchiert und gegengecheckt hat jörg
vielen vielen dank dass du vor ort bist
und natürlich behältst du dort den fall
für uns weiter im auge danke dir
schonmal jörg
und an dieser stelle bleibt eben noch
einmal zu sagen was für eine großartige
nachricht julia aus berlin war fast 48
stunden alleine irgendwo da draußen im
wald in tschechien und wir alle wir
haben so sehr gehofft und gebangt dass
es ihr irgendwie gut geht und am ende
wir hier eine positive nachricht
tatsächlich vermelden können und das
haben wir getan julia lebt es geht ihr
okay sie ist im krankenhaus und ihre
familie auf dem weg dahin das war es mit
dieser sondersendung wieder informiert
sie natürlich weiter auf bte und danke
fürs zuschauen
[Musik]